[Musique]
imaginez que l'on prie le carrefour
médicis de son jet d'eau que l'on
arrache à la rue soufflot sont chères
panthéon
que resterait-il du quartier latin les
cafés par dizaines ils se pressaient
s'entassent les uns contre les autres
après s'être paré sans pudeur de noms
prestigieux ils ouvrent tout grand leurs
bras aux étudiants de paris
[Musique]
l'heure de pointe se situe entre midi et
deux heures
et l'affluence est telle que l'on se
demande ce qu'il adviendrait de tous ces
étudiants
s'il n'y avait pas de café pour les
recevoir
ne croyez surtout pas que ces jeunes
gens viennent ici pour boire mais il
faut bien payer sa place comme dans tous
les pays acp qu'est-ce que vous veniez
madmoizelle com onglet ou café en café
en général moi j'ai pas dis express
souvent un café crème pourquoi café très
bien c'est parce que c'est moins cher et
l union oui emploi vous mademoiselle
moi j'ai fait mes études pour apprendre
le français
ici à paris je suis depuis janvier
puis des coups à la seconde et de quel
pays venez vous voici dans le monde
vous êtes allemand mais de vous monsieur
je suis malgache et jeu terminant
seulement mes études en physique
nucléaire
est ce que dans votre pays en allemagne
ah non moi vous habitez oui est ce qu'il
ya des cafés comme à paris oh non vous
savez c'est tout à fait différent en
offre il y à des cafés plus élégant plus
chic
c'est à dire pour les étudiants on
trouve pas d'étudiants trouvent les
vielles dames dimanche la tarte et les
étudiants il y a une chose spéciale sa
péniche pas c'est à dire on boit du lait
une mixte chèques et des choses comme ça
là on trouve des étudiants mais pas dans
les cafés qu'est-ce que vous dépenser
beaucoup d'argent pour venir au café oui
oui oui oui le point consacré un petit
budget pour le cap et les cigarettes
venez vous seul au café
j'y vais seul mais je suis sûr de
rencontrer des amis quand je suis c'est
que je rencontre pas d'amis je m'en vais
dans quelques minutes parce que je ne
pas rester seul dans un café pourquoi
vous savez la jeune fille sur scène car
il ya trop de gens qui regardent et moi
je suis timide je ne peux pas rester
c'est dans un café je vais je vois mon
café à mehdi je mens je sais mais je
sais pas ce que je peux pas manger
toujours dans un restaurant ça coûte
trop cher je bois mon café mon service
et s'il ya quelqu'un pas d'amis je m'en
vais tout de suite vous êtes vous
rencontrés connu tous les deux
voilà longtemps j'avais les who is on my
own oui moi j'étais une semaine ici à
paris j'étais tout je connaissais
personne
j'étais moyen j'avais des cartes uicc et
avec un ami regardez toujours je pouvais
faire était seul j'étais content de
trouver quelqu'un pour râler quand vous
retournerez en allemagne est-ce que vous
garderez un souvenir spécial pour les
cafés du quartier latin
oui ça c'est sûr vraiment ça me manquera
beaucoup
des études de sciences économiques
c'était de mathématiques une licence de
matinée
vous êtes je vois alors mal sur we are
continue
l'école normale supérieure de contenu de
fontenay autrement dit vous êtes un peu
éloigné de paris
j'habite en banlieue mais je prends tous
mes cours à la faculté de paris à la
sorbonne iere nouvelle faculté de
sciences à la halle aux vins autrement
dit vous avez peut-être temps mort nous
avons beaucoup de temps morts dans la
journée
c'est pour ça que nous occupons souvent
à venir au café et pourquoi n'allez-vous
pas dans une bibliothèque
bibliothèque je n'aime pas cette fois
oh
ton post est
et vous importe l'ambiance café
d'ici là bio
vous sentir
[Musique]
alors toi seul mais entouré de personnes
et c'est beaucoup plus vivant par
exemple
bio tech c'est moins sûr fait comme
atmosphère moins compassé est-ce que
vous pensez que c'est journée dans un
café ça peut ajouter quelque chose à la
formation
oh je crois
oui mais bon jeu
cela nous apprend à ne pas nous prendre
au sérieux parce qu'on va tellement de
gens dans les quartiers qui se prennent
au sérieux que ça nous fait une bourde
philosophie de ce point de vue là est ce
la seule raison
on rencontre des gens nombreuses
personnes différentes et
ce même approche pour la vie lorsque
vous
logan est ce que vous souhaitez
rencontrer des gens d'un autre
j'aime pouvoir en remontrer que c'est
difficile ça l'est toujours dans les
cafés que prépare des étudiants n'ont
même quand je vais dans un quartier
différent ce sont les gens qui sont de
mon milieu avec lequel je dois beaucoup
d'étudiants essayé de parler de leur
travail
donc ces seniors d empêcher bien sûr et
on essaie de faire parler d'autre chose
alors ça commence par le temps ensuite
de la conversation dévie on en arrive
aux au livre qu'on lit
spectacle le convoi aux promenades qu'on
fait
c'est assez varié où on joue on fait des
jeux de quelques fois des jeux de
société vous êtes vous contre le café à
tikrit où l'on est sûr de rencontrer des
amis non je ne sais pas pour cela j'aime
tous les cafés l'insolite et je n'aime
pas avoir une petite habitude dans un
calcul non sédentaires déjà bourgeois
rcan arrivé je préfère me promener
quelque chose à temps de cochon
c'est par une petite aventure voilà
chaque fois que dans un quartier une
petite histoire nouvelle
il ya une espèce de griserie à se mettre
dans la foule et ça fait un peu tourner
la tête c'est pas désagréable
ainsi dans ce grand café où l'on vient
tuer le temps l'insolite l aventure
ouvre des horizons qui tiennent fermer
les murs épais les grandes écoles mais
on ne vient pas au café uniquement pour
rêver certains étudiants y travaillent
est il possible non d'étudier au milieu
du bruit et de la foule cette question
nous l'avons posée aux clients du
rouquet le café attitré des étudiants en
médecine de la nouvelle faculté presque
des étudiants en médecine dont beaucoup
au café
la plupart oui
vous travaillez quelques mots café
ça dépend des caractères pourquoi tous
les pans les caractères bayonnais qui
peut pas rayer
ça vous paraît quand même difficile
pour vous c'est absolument impossible de
travailler oui ces défauts quelle
matière ça n'est pas telle matière vous
pensez qu'on peut étudier la médecine au
café
non
c'est un peu trop sérieux le droit le
droit
mademoiselle vous arrivez à travailler
malgré des bouées dans tout ce monde le
faut qu'est ce que vous faites en ce
moment
bien je relève des notes sur jean-paul
ça qu'est ce que vous faites le métier
et ça je peux parler leur décor à votre
école de dessin est loin du café le
rouquet non à l'état de phares du dragon
alors pourquoi avez vous au café je n'y
a pas d'autres lieux où ça et à
l'académie je suis n'y a pas de style où
on puisse travailler en chauffe entre
les arts de pau
mais il ya des bibliothèques en pâtit
oui mais je ne suis pas une étudiante et
je suis très difficile pour moi parce
que ferais tu si bien justement et j'ai
que ça en somme comme ressource mais
pourquoi ne rentrez-vous pas chez vous
alors le midi comme travailler parce que
c'est encore un beau problème je suis en
banlieue et je ne peux pas rentrer parce
que je n'ai que deux heures autres mes
cours à midi
et tous les midis et
vous voulez travailler pendant un café
oui passants et les gens qui sont autour
de vous n'essayez pas de vous de vous
parler ne vous dérange pas même si
quelquefois bien sûr malheureusement m
vous connaissez des gens qui gagnent ici
au rendez vous les trouvez ici non
voyants pour ça que je suis là et je
peux travailler parce que vous ne
connaissez personne absence de lieu de
travail manque de place dans les
bibliothèques et le maniement du
domicile
ce sont là des problèmes que rencontrent
fréquemment les étudiants le café ne
peut en être la solution
mais rendons nous maintenant au souffle
au le souffle au qui rejoint les grandes
traditions du procope ici comme autant
de voltaire on parle littérature
philosophie politique
la faculté de droit est ainsi entouré
d'un certain nombre de petits cafés où
l'on s'agite beaucoup à droite à gauche
on discute ferme mais un étudiant en
droit
n'est-il pas à l'homme politique en
puissance
je fais du droit première année de droit
et 2e année souffle pourquoi deuxième
année de soufflot un oui parce que j'ai
redoublé ma première année
ça fait deux ans que vous veniez trois
cafés donc se propage nous propose soit
le café directement évidemment j'y passe
un certain nombre d'heures ou café je ne
crois pas que ce soit la raison de mon
échec mon examen vous avez toujours
habité paris oui toujours habité paris
comment avez vous découvert alors le
souffle d'abord j'ai découvert parce
qu'il est prêt la faculté et nous
pouvons vivre dans la petite chambre de
bonne je suis obligé de sortir de chez
moi et ainsi je suis amené j'étais amené
à fréquenter le souffle au là j'ai fait
des connaissances d'amis sur le plan
politique
je suis senti tout de suite une certaine
coloration politique qui existait avant
mon arrivée et c'est à ce moment-là que
j'ai
j'ai fréquenté ne plus en plus
régulièrement le souffle mais cette
couleur politique elle était amenée oslo
par les patrons d où les noirs en au
monument par les patrons les patrons la
matière qu'on preuve de neutralité
absolue mais il n'ignore pas évidemment
notre pensée politique parce qu'elle est
visible nous laissons nos journaux nous
laissons nos livres et ainsi de suite
lors des manifestations tout d'un coup
le souffle au et plein de mise après les
villes parce que tout le monde est parti
à la manifestation et une demi heure
après ils se retrouvent rampi comme par
hasard parce que tout le monde est
rentré la manifestation tout le monde
écoute la radio pour connaître les
résultats et la répercussion de notre
manifestation et c'est une vraiment
disent ils est ce qu'il ya des cafés où
vous n'iriez pas un oui très
certainement les cours du café au droit
d'abord même voire extrême droite
évidemment je serai pas ne serait pas
possible d'aller on sait qu'à fait tant
qu'on va écouter leurs conversations
si l'on crée une cafétéria l'intérieur
la faculté de droit est ce que vous
iriez évidemment je prendrai peut-être
un café mais ça n'aurait pas le même
rôle que le souffle aux quarts
évidemment
on rencontrait que les étudiants en
droit
or il est souhaitable que les étudiants
et une endroit connaissent d'autres
étudiants en sciences en lettres que
j'ai fait une licence de ski des
sciences et maintenant je fais un
troisième cycle physique parce que
j'aime au souffle aussi rencontré des
gens qui font du droit avec qui on peut
discuter refaire le monde en un sens oui
ma parole ce sont toujours des gens des
milieux plus que le board mieux ils sont
toujours des étudiants vous ne cherchez
pas les gens les cafés où il y aurait
des légendes un autre milieu et les
employés les ouvriers
je ne crois pas qu'en allant dans un
café où il y aurait des ouvriers je
pourrais rentrer en contact avec les
yeux brillaient je crois qu'il faut il
faut beaucoup plus de contacts avec eux
quelques vagues d'un café pour pour
entrer dans leur domaine c'est
uniquement le côté politique alors qui
vous attire soufflot le côté politique
oui mais aussi le côté culturel le soir
lorsqu'on a envie de sortir
on passe au souffle au comme ça et on
voit les copains qu'on peut emmener au
cinéma ou au théâtre parce que je n'aime
pas beaucoup sentir les deux seuls le
soir c'est évident et ça fait fonctions
un peu d' agences de tourisme
le spectacle est aussi un lieu où l'on
peut vous joindre de huy a fait ça dans
nos champs nous n'avons évidemment pas
le téléphone et nous avons besoin de
passer des communications téléphoniques
et aussi surtout d'en recevoir
or nous avons besoin d'avoir un local
fixe pour recevoir des communications
téléphoniques mais aussi le garçon
cassez vous avez oui nous avertissons le
la des messages se taira même des mots
mêmes de l'argent c'est vraiment eu un
deuxième deuxième appartement quelque
sorte ça ça correspond à une cité
absolument c'est absolument vital on ne
fait pas ce passé d'avoir un café au
quartier latin proche de la faculté
proche de nos organismes politiques et
syndicaux l'unef se faire arrêter
selon vous le cac cédant indispensable à
la vie des étudiants ou sa réponse
absolument indispensable il faut que
l'étudiant puisse se fixer en alu
maintenant peut-être pourrait-on trouver
un autre lieu de ses étudiants mais
en l'occurrence il n'y a que le gars
fait tour à tour lieu de détente de
récréation salle de travail ou scène
politique centre d'échangés culturels
les cafés du quartier latin sont le
refuge des étudiants de paris qui
s'échappe en de leur école de leurs
facultés se retrouve entre copains et au
milieu de ce spectacle permanent espère
un jour ou l'autre une rencontre avec la
vie
[Musique]